[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de Parlement Hebdo retour sur les
temps forts politiques et parlementaires
s le regard de notre invité et on
accueille cette semaine François Noël
buffet bonjour bonjour vous êtes
sénateur les républicains du rô et
président de la commission des Lois du
Sénat et on va revenir avec vous sur le
projet de loi immigration qui a été
largement censuré par le Conseil
constitutionnelle 35 articles
totalementou partiellement retoqués dont
de nombreuses mesures de dircissement
qui avaient été adopté sous la pression
de la droite et considéré comme des
cavaliers
législatifs les députés ont voté
l'inscription dans la Constitution de la
liberté garantie pour les femmes
d'accéder à l'IVG le projet de loi sera
soumis au vote solennel de l'Assemblée
nationale le 30 janvier avant de partir
devant les sénateurs fin février et puis
on reviendra bien sûr sur la fronte des
agriculteurs qui se durcit explosion des
charges multiplication des normes prix
du carburant ou encore baisse des
revenus des revenus les raisons de la
colères sont
multiples le Conseil constitutionnel a
donc censuré 40 % de la loi immigration
les mesures de durcissement du texte
ajouté par les sénateurs les
républicains ont été en grande partie
retoqué car considérés comme sans lien
avec le projet de loi initial de géralde
daranin à la droite crie au scandale et
demande à Emmanuel Macron une nouvelle
loi immigration Jonathan du prieèz c'est
une décision aux allures de sentence
pour le texte immigration le Conseil
constitutionnel a décidé de censurer une
très large partie de ce projet de loi 40
% des mesures de ce texte hautement
inflammable sont donc retoquées en
premier lieu les Sages ont fait tomber
32 cavaliers législatifs des mesures
jugées trop éloignées du texte originel
exit donc le durcissement de l'accès aux
prestations sociales du regroupement
familial ou encore de l'instauration
d'une caution retour pour les étudiants
étrangers mais cette large censure est
surtout un revers de taille pour la
droite sénatoriale à l'origine du
durcissement de ce texte elle est
contestable elle est absolument
contestable et finalement le Conseil
constitutionnel interdit au
législateurs de prendre des mesures
aussi le Conseil constitutionnel a fait
tomber trois mesures sur le fond la
tenue d'un débat annuel au Parlement
pour fixer des quotas migratoires le
relev de photos et d'empreintes sans le
consentement des clandestins ou en c le
changement de procédure d'examen d'un
titre de séjour la censure de ces
articles revigore en tout cas les
parlementaires de gauche vend debout
contre ce texte et à l'initiative de
deux des quatre recours auprès du
Conseil constitutionnel c'est une bonne
nouvelle je me réjouis de cette décision
du du Conseil constitutionnel on ne
s'assoit pas sur la constitution et sur
nos principes fondamentaux et je suis
heureux que le Conseil constitutionnel
et rappeler par exemple que la
préférence nationale n'est pas soluble
dans la publ et dans les valeurs de la
République le texte conserve toutefois
un large volet de simplification des
procédures pour les expulsions des
étrangers délinquant notamment ce que
souhaitait le gouvernement malgré cette
large censure Emmanuel Macron demande à
géralde Darmanin de promulguer la loi
dans les meilleurs délais François Noël
buffet comment vous réagissez à cette
décision du Conseil constitutionnel
est-ce que c'est un holdup démocratique
comme le dit ricoti le patron du parti
les républicains écoutez moi je respecte
la décision du Conseil constitutionnel
il y a pas de difficulté là-dessus en
revanche on peut quand même s'interroger
au-delà de ce texte
lui-même sur l'application extrêmement
stricte des dispositions de l'article 45
de la Constitution c'est celui qui est
relatif au cavalier législatif je
rappelle que il a été modifié en 2008 et
que pour permettre justement que les les
parlementaires puisse amender un texte
et il est indiqué que l'amendement doit
avoir un lien direct avec le direct ou
un direct avec le texte donc là on est
sur l'inprétation qui est vraiment très
très rigoureuse de la première partie de
de de ce de cette
disposition effectivement euh ce qu'on a
essayé de faire au Sénat c'est ce que je
voudrais rappeler sur ce texte on a 26
articles qui arrivent au départ d'un
texte du Gouvernement on estime que il
faut une politique migratoire pour la
France donc on complète le dispositif
présenté par le gouvernement toutes les
mesures qui sont proposées sont des
mesures qui sont relatives à l'
immigration il y a aucun doute
d'ailleurs personne ne le conteste et on
donne finalement dans ce texte une sorte
cohérence globale qui traite pas
seulement de l'immigration irrégulière
comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui mais qui
traite aussi de l'immigration régulière
alors qu'estce quelle conclusion oui
quelle conclusion conclusion estce
qu'une majorité souhaitait ce
durcissement en matière d'imigration
exactement la conclusion c'est que les
32 articles qui font l'objet d'une
censure au titre de cavaliers n'ont pas
été jugés sur le fond donc ils n'ont pas
été remis en cause sur le fond et pour
cause puisqu'on a traité que la
procédure et que la forme donc je pense
qu'il est important que le gouvernement
qui par ailleurs pourquoi le Conseil
constitutionnel ça veut dire qu'il
aurait décidé de ne se se s'en tenir à
la il a considéré que il fallait s'en
tenir exclusivement au texte d'origine
déposé par le Gouvernement qu'on ne
pouvait pas aller au-delà de ce qui
avait été déposé par le Gouvernement et
là il décide par un moyen de procédure
d'écarter tant deux articles il en a le
droit avec une interprétation très
stricte de l'article 45 et de ce fait ne
juge pas sur le fond alors ce qui est
intéressant aujourd'hui une fois qu'on a
constaté tout cela c'est que le
gouvernement qui pendant les débats qui
pendant les débats par l'intermédiaire
de son ministre avait soutenu la
majorité de ces amendements il suffit de
revoir les débats et on verra très vite
que l'amendement déposé par le Sénat a
été adopté a été a été soit un avis
favorable soit n'a pas été remis en
cause par le gouvernement après un vote
en commission je suis un peu technique
mais c'est ça bah devrait immédiatement
redéposer un texte sur la base de ces
amendements qu'il avait souhaité qui par
ailleurs ont fait l'objet d'un accord en
commission mix paritaire ça n'est tout
de même pas négligeable on n'est pas
dans la République des juges Bruno
rotaillot estime que le Conseil
constitutionnel a censuré je cite la
voix des Français qu'est-ce que vous
vous dites-vous je je ne je n'utilise
rarement des propos aussi fort parce que
nous aurons d'autres textes il y aura
d'autres sujets mais la question est
quand même posée de l'interprétation
extrêmement stricte de l'article 40
de la Constitution il faut le modifier
cet article 45 en tous les cas il faut
qu'on ait un échange très clair je pense
peut-être même informel dans un premier
temps avec le Conseil constitutionnel
sur la façon dont il interprète cet
article 45 on a le droit de le faire il
y a rien d'interdit là-dessus et
peut-être qu'il faudra à un moment un
autre réfléchir à la manière de le
rédiger différemment pour ne pas certes
ne pas tomber dans une inflation
législative et d'amendement qui soit
considérable mais tout de même sur des
sujets de cette nature on puisse donner
la coréence à un texte parce que ça pose
une question quand même sur le rôle du
Parlement la matière alors la droite
effectivement demande au gouvernement et
bien une nouvelle loi immigration pour
introduire ces mesures qui ont été
retoquées mais Emmanuel Macron le
président de la République a demandé une
application rapide une promulgation
rapide de la loi immigration initiale
qui a été acceptée par les sages est-ce
que vous craignez que le président
souhaite passer à autre chose et ne
réintroduise pas vos mesures c'est une
crainte qui est réelle euh au bénéfice
de la décision d'hier le texte va être
publié rapidement donc mise en uvre
rapidement notons tout de même que toute
la partie procédure dans ce texte est
issu du Sénat puisqu'il est issu d'un
rapport que nous avions commis en mai
2022 donc c'est au moins un point de
satisfaction s'il en fallait un ça vient
de chez nous dans rapport que j'avais
commis donc de ce point de vue là j'ai
une petite gloire personnelle mais ça
n'a pas beaucoup d'importance je crain
qu'effectivement ils ne reviennent pas
sur ce texte et sur ces mesures qui ont
été censurées s'ils ne le font pas nous
le ferons pour une raison cette fois-ci
non pas technique mais politique une
politique migratoire c'est un cap c'est
une
stratégie et donc on ne l'a pas
totalement à travers le texte
aujourd'hui qui va s'appliquer mais si
vous remettez en débat toutes ces
mesures vous convenez qu'il y a peu de
chance qu'elle soit adoptée et votter il
y a peutêtre il y a peut-être peu de
chance pour qu'elle aboutisse mais si on
ne le fait pas il ne se passera rien
donc vous allez le faire quand même bien
un moment où il faut essayer de faire
avaner ch sur l'migration si le
gouvernement ne le fait pas car je une
fois de plus ça a fait l'objet d'un
accord en commission mixte paritaire
majorité opposition euh se sont mis
d'accord sur ce texte donc il a été voté
pourquoi ne serait-il pas voté une
deuxième fois cette fois-ci sur un
véhicule législatif qui soit une PPL ou
une proposition de loi comment vous
analysez les conséquences à moyen terme
dans la suite du quinquena de cet
épisode est-ce que d'abord le grand
gagnant c'est le rassemblement national
qui dénonce l'impuissance publique sur
l'immigration et puis est-ce que ça va
tendre encore un peu plus la relation
exécutif les républiquain effectivement
si on sort du texte mais l'événement
lui-même sans parler du du fond je pense
sincèrement dans le contexte actuel de
facture du pays favorise
incontestablement le Front national il
vont ti un bénéfice d'ailleurs il ne
cesse de le dire sur tous les plateaux
quand bien même ils a vé le texte mais
contester d'abord le texte puis ensuite
voter à la dernière minute il ne cesse
de de le revendiquer donc je pense qu'il
vont en tirer un profit ce qui n'est pas
pour de mon point de vue une bonne chose
pour être très clair et puis enfin je
pense que ça va attendre les relations
oui singulièrement à l'Assemblée
nationale je crains que les relations
soient soi compliqué deviennent
compliqué la prochaine étape sur le
sujet migratoire c'est la réforme de
l'Ame l'aide médicale de l'état qui
permet de soigner les étudiants en en
situation régulière des étrangers des
étrangers des étrangers pardon en
situation irrégulière vous aviez trouvé
euh la droite à trouvver un compromis
avec ellisabeth borne pour s'entendre
sur une réforme prochaine de cette ame
est-ce que vous pensez qu'elle aura lieu
est-ce que vous souhaitez une grande
réforme ou vous pensez qu'il y aura
plutôt une réformecoutz ça fait partie
de la disction texte migratoire nous
avons sorti du texte l'aide médicale
d'État promesse a été faite par le
gouvernement qu'un projet serait déposé
en début d'année j'ai interrogé le
Premier ministre il y a 15 jours
question d'actualité il m'a indiqué que
c'était toujours d'actualité et qu'il le
ferait dans un délai assez rapide sans
en fixer vraiment les limites donc on
s'imagine que c'est dans le courant du
premier trimestre il faut travailler sur
ce sujet il y a un rapport qui été fait
par Monsieur Patrick stéphanini qui est
tout à fait intéressant et sur lequel on
peut objectiver les constats mais il y a
des mesures à prendre c'est
incontestable rapport qui dit qu'il faut
pas forcément restreindre le panier de
soin ce que veul les républain question
la question est de rester sur le
principe du soins il y a pas de
difficulté là-dessus la question du
panier de soins en tous les cas de la
nature de certains soins est quand même
posée mais évidemment on va pas les
choses ne sont pas réduites à un point
tel que au bout du compte ça
n'aboutirait pas mais la question du
contrôle me paraît totalement
essentielle dernière question sur ce
sujet de l'immigration est-ce que les
républicains doivent continuer à
s'accrocher à l'idée d'une réforme
constitutionnelle sur l'immigration
notamment pour permettre un référendum
des Français sur ce sujet he brun roto a
l'air a l'air d' être très attaché très
attaché mais le problème c'est que vous
n'avez pas de majorité au Parlement sur
ce texte seul le rassemblement national
est pour vous savez que c'est la réforme
de l'article 11 de la Constitution qui
est en cause qui permettra d'avoir un
référendum sur l'immigration on déposera
le texte est déposé je rappelle que il
est déposé à l'Assemblée nationale il
avait été retiré pour des raisons de
circonstances parce que nous avions le
texte immigration qui était en et puis
les centristes étaient contre aussi
voilà pas certain que une majorité mais
néanmoins on peut tout de même poser le
débat à tout le moins poser le débat
essayer de faire av c'est l'idée on
verra évidemment qu'on sent bien que sur
le plan politique le process est en
difficulté alors même que le Président
de la République s'était déclaré
rappelez-vous dans les entretiens de
Saint-Denis en tous les cas la première
réunion favorable à cela et qu'il est
revenu dessus après tout mais toutefois
j'avais entendu pas très longtemps qu'il
était de nouveau favorable donc
finalement l'espoir est possible alors
l'autre sujet de la semaine c'est l'IVG
sera-t-elle inscrite dans la
Constitution cette semaine en tout cas
l'Assemblée nationale a largement
approuvé la liberté garantie pour les
femmes d'y accéder les débats ont été
assez apres entre majorité et la gauche
d'un côté et puis les élus LR de l'autre
la proposition de loi constitutionnelle
sera considérée comme adoptée après un
vote solennel puis elle ira au Sénat
résumé de la séance avec els Mandin
Gava la constitutionnalisation de l'IVG
a franchi une première étape dans
l'hémicycle votant 114 exprimés 112
majorités 57 pour 99 contre 13
l'Assemblée nationale a adopté un peu
plus tôt le garde des saau avait défendu
la nécessité de faire entrer dans la
Constitution la liberté garantit à la
femme d'avoir recours à une IVG la
liberté de recourir à l'IVG n'est pas
une liberté comme les autres car elle
permett aux femmes de décider de leur
avenir sur les bans de l'hémicycle un
large consensus malgré l'opposition de
certains députés les républicains
un vote solennel est prévu mardi sans
surprise l'assemblée adoptera le texte
labal est désormais dans le camp du
Sénat en février dernier la chambre
haute avait consacré la liberté de la
femme à mettre fin à sa grossesse une
majorité des sénateurs de droite avait
voté contre le président du Sénat Gérard
Larcher a réaffirmé son opposition au
projet du gouvernement je pense que la
Constitution n'est pas un catalogue de
droits sociaux et socié par tradition je
ne vote pas mais je vous donne un avis
très personnel en conscience je ne pense
que la Constitution c'est pas ce
catalogue là il est impératif que
l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat vote
un texte rédigé dans les mêmes termes
pour que le Président de la République
puisse réunir le Congrès François Noël
buffet une fois adopté par l'Assemblée
la réforme constitutionnelle doit être
votée dans les mêmes termes exactement
les mêmes termes par le Sénat le débat
sera à fin février alors qu'est-ce que
vous dites vous en tant que président de
la commission des Lois du Sénat est-ce
que vous êtes optimiste ou vous pensez
comme Gérard Larcher et une grande
majorité de vos collègues etir euh que
qu'il ne faut pas inscrire les VG dans
la Constitution est-ce que vous êtes
contre ce texte alors déjà on va
commencer par redire les choses
sereinement le Sénat au mois de février
dernier s'est prononcé pour et il a S
prononcer sur une rédaction il fa
prononcer pour oui sur une rédaction du
Sénat de la réforme constitutionnelle
qui est en partie reprise par le
gouvernement cette fois-ci et qui a été
en part proposée à l'Assemblée nationale
mais qui a été modifié première chose
auourdi plus le même texte c'est plus le
même texte et le texte arrive dans ces
circonstances là garantie a été ajouté
et là la liberté garantie pour les la
rédac du mois de février dernier adopté
au Sénat a été rajouté le terme garantie
et le texte arrive dans ces conditions
là au Sénat deuxième chose il faut
redire faut être honnête et dire les
choses telles qu'elles sont sur le plan
strictement juridique l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse est protégée par
notre Constitution à travers une
jurisprudence constante de celle-ci et
il n'y a pas de ce point de vue-là de
risque majeur immédiat imminent de
remettre en cause ce droit qui est un
droit acquis et qui doit effectivement
être un droit absolument protégé il y a
pas aucun doute là-dessus et je n'ai pas
une seconde d'hésitation à dire que
naturellement il faut protéger ce droit
là deuxième chose faut-il l'inscrire
dans la Constitution pour le renforcer
puisque c'est ça l'idée alors disons les
choses clairement sur le plan juridique
ce n'est pas une nécessité absolue mais
on sent bien qu' une poussée très forte
une volonté très forte de le faire si
nous devons aboutir à quelque chose je
souhaite que nous y aboutissions qu'à la
condition que la rédaction qui soit
obtenue soit une rédaction qui soit
parfaitement j' presque que dire d'un
point de vue juridique qui soit d'une
très bonne qualité et je ne suis pas
tout à fait satisfait par la rédaction
qui est proposée par l'Assemblée
nationale il y aura donc un débat à la
commission des lois sur cette rédaction
et j'espère qu'on
trouvera le chemin qu'il faudra
j'indique quand même sur ce
point chacun a sa liberté totale de vote
et qu' n'y a aucune contrainte pour
personne quelle serait cette rédaction
selon vous parce que on rappelle que
vous avez voté contre en févrierin la
rédaction avec la la mention de la
liberté des les alors les choses les les
chos vous savez les les choses évoluent
mais moi je tiens pour acquis que le
Sénat s'est déjà prononcé une fois et il
s'est déjà prononcé favorablement donc
il faut laisser au Sénat sa liberté de
vote évidemment et que chacun vote en
conscience ce qu'il veut il y a aucun
doute là-dessus mais je veux qu'on ait
une base juridique qui soit solide c'est
mon rôle de président de la commission
des lois de veiller à ce que la
rédaction qui soit proposée soit une
rédaction qui soit solide et qui
s'insrivve parfait la consti donc vous
n'allez pas tomber si on comprend bien
dans le piège politique que semblerait
vouloir vous tendre Emmanuel Macron en
vous faisant passer vous les LR pour un
parti rétrograde sur les droits des
femmes é non mais enfin c'est
complètement stupide franchement vouloir
faire passer le mouvement au nous-mêm et
ou moi-même comme étant rétrograde enfin
c'est unee stupidité absolue j'imagine
pas un seul instant que le Président de
la République en soit là bon ENF en tous
les cas je l'espère donc vous ESP
évidemment protecteur du droits des
femmes et il y a aucune difficulté
là-dessus mais le mettre en doute c'est
déjà quasiment une insulte hein donc
encore une fois malgré l'opposition
assez ferme de Jard Larché opposition
personnelle duésition personnel du
président du Sénat ça veut dire qu'il y
a selon quand même une chance que ce
texte soit adopté au Sénat ça va être
très serré Le Vot écoutz si je pense que
le vote sera serré
mais rappelez-vous celui du mois de
février l'année dernière il y a un an et
le Sénat s'est prononcé dans la liberté
de chacun et c'est ce
qui pour moi très bien mais pour moi
c'est une condition absolue que chacun
se prononce librement et sans contrainte
si je puis dire et que la rédaction qui
doit sortir si rédaction on doit arriver
au bout soit une rédaction qui soit
parfaitement équilibrée et qui soit
parfaitement de très de très bonne
qualité rédactionnel car une fois de
plus je redis mais ça vient d'être dit
encore par le Conseil constitutionnel on
ne touche pas la Constitution n'importe
comment et on doit impérativement être
responsable de cel faut enlever le mot
garantie à liberté oui parce que je
pense qu'il n'apporte rien à la
circonstance HM alors on aura le débat
en tout cas même si vous votez le chemin
législatif pour ce projet de loi
constitutionnel sera loin d'être terminé
il faut réunir le Congrès députés
sénateurs à Versailles on a déjà eu une
date le mois de mars Emmanuel Macron
souhaiterait que ce soit définitivement
adopté avant la journée de la femme
alors est-ce qu'il va vite en besoges
c'est un mars c'est un chiffon rouge en
fait c'est une forme de pression qui est
exercée sur le Parlement en disant
dépêchez-vous dépêchez-vous parce que
j'ai une stratégie de communication
derrière soyons sérieux c'est une erreur
pour d'avoir fix oui je pense que c'est
une provocation puisqueune erreur une
provocation c'est inutile faisons le
que le Parlement fasse son travail
correctement et quand le travail sera
fait correctement et que les votes
seront intervenus et ben il sera
peut-être temps à ce moment-là de réunir
le Congrès mais très sérieusement
respectons le chemin parlementaire la
première des choses me semble-t-il que
l'on doit avoir donc un congrès de
Versailles début mars c'est peu probable
selon vous je crois que ça a été annoncé
un peu vite alors c'est beaucoup c'est
trè voors c'est très présomptuueux
peut-être plus tard voors peut-être plus
tard mais en tous les cas laissons le
débat parlementaire enfin tout le monde
réclame le débat parlementaire tout le
monde veut pouvoir s'exprimer et ben
qu'on laisse le Parlement s'exprimer
dernier thème de cette émission la crise
agricole François Noël buffet une crise
agricole qui a secoué le Parlement cette
semaine notamment lors des questions au
gouvernement les sénateurs écologistes
ont accusé l'exécutif de faire de
l'écologie la principale cause des
problèmes actuels de l'agriculture
française la problématique numéro 1 est
bien celle de la faiblesse du revenu
agricole qui épuise les agriculteurs
votre gouvernement et le syndicat
majoritaire font de la diversion en
réduisant la contestation à celle des
normes environnementales à la question
des j chers le syndicat majoritaire
agite l'écologie comme un épouvantail
pour mieux masquer les échecs sinistres
des politiques menées depuis des
décennies on a fait de l'écologie un
épouvantail collectivement monsieur
salmon pardon parce que quand on vient
accumuler des normes et des contraintes
comment voulez-vous que ce soit perçu
par les
agriculteursieur on a besoin de
réconcilier or on est bien dans une
situation où les agriculteurs le vivent
en permanence comme une punition ou
comme une mise en acccusation on a un
sujet d'image il faut qu'on arrête dans
les médias et à longueur de médias de
dire du mal de l'agriculture et de de de
montrer une agriculture qui n'est pas la
réalité de l'agriculture française avant
d'évoquer le fond de cette crise
agricole parlons d'ordre public les
agriculteurs ont mené beaucoup d'actions
coup de point cette semaine le le pays
est vraiment bloqué et Gérald d'agnen le
ministre d'intérieur estime qu'il faut
laisser faire les agriculteurs que ce
sont des coup de sang légitime je le
cite est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
est-ce que c'est pas du laxisme de la
part du ministre de l'Intérieur qui est
quand même responsable de l'ordre public
je ne suis pas d'accord avec la position
du ministre de l'intérieur quand on est
ministre de l'intérieur on fait
respecter l'ordre quel que soit celui
qui manifeste qu'on l'aime ou qu'on
l'aime pas la question n'est pas
celle-ci ça s'appelle l'ordre public
fonctionnement républicain de ce pays
donc on fait respectecter la règle si
les règles sont respectées et que les
gens manifestent comme il est d'usage de
façon organisée déclarée et respectueuse
de tout le monde il y a évidemment aucun
problème mais à partir du moment où un
manifestant quel qu'il soit quel que
soit sa la la légitimité de sa
contestation enfint les règles de la
République pose des difficultés bah oui
il y a un moment il faut il faut arrêter
les choses il faut remettre un peu
d'ordre ce que je veux dire par là c'est
qu' il y a façon et façon de remettre de
l'ordre hein on peut le faire de façon
tout à fait consensuelle discuter
aborder les sujets trouver des points
d'accord avant de passer j'allais dire à
des mesures beaucoup plus coeritives
donc ne ne mettons pas comme principe
que finalement parce qu'on est gentil ou
parce qu'on aime bien les uns ou les
autres on est plus souple avec les uns
ou avec les autres enfin je veux dire
c'est déjà contraire à tous les
principes de la République justement
metons bon ordre làdedans vous n'avez
pas justement le sentiment d'un d'un
deux poids de mesure quand on voit la
manière dont on peut être réprimé par
exemple en tout cas certaines actions
menées par les écologistes oui mais
alors attendez c'est qu différent de
mener la guerre à la police à Sainte
Soline avec des moyens d'une violence
extraordinaire parfois même dans les
émeut avec la
volontéé la réponse était parfaitement
légitime que de manifester avec son
tracteur de jeter un peu de lisier et de
ne pas casser la moitié des outils de la
République enfin tout de même il faut
quand même faire des différences
là-dessus c'est pas parce qu'on est
responsable de l'ordre public que l'on
doit pas prendre en considération
effectivement les cas particuliers ne
mélangeons pas tout les agriculteurs ne
manifestent pas comment on manifest
manifester l'extrême gauche à
saint-seline pour donner un exemple qui
soit concret pour pour nos concitoyens
alors sur le fond de cette crise
agricole François nouëel buffet ce
mal-être des agriculteurs il est causé
par quoi est-ce qu'il est causé par
l'écologie est-ce que c'est la
principale raison les normes
environnementales ou est-ce que c'est en
réalité une histoire ancienne c'est en
réalité une histoire ancienne mais pour
beaucoup de sujets la France n'a plus de
stratégie de souveraineté on parle de
l'agriculture aujourd'hui on pourrait
parler de beaucoup d'autres choses la
stratégie industrielle la stratégie de
l' je n'use personne je dis c'est de la
responsabilité des politiques et de ceux
qui dirigent que de veiller à ce que la
souveraineté de la France dans tous ces
domaines soit absolument préservé
premier point deuxième point nous savons
qu'en matière agricole les choses ne
sont pas simples nous avons besoin
d'avoir une filière qui soit pour dans
laquelle nos agriculteurs puissent vivre
de leur travail et aujourd'hui ce n'est
pas le cas puisque la majorité enfin pas
pour tous mais pour une partie d'entre
eux ils ne vivent pas de leur travail
puisqu'ils sont subventionnés et on voit
bien 300 € par mois 400 € par mois et
des revenus extrêmement bas alors que le
le travail est considérable donc on a un
sujet donc ce sujet-l il doit se
résoudre de façon j'allais dire
économique avec une stratégie économique
qui leur permet de vivre de leur travail
alors y a-t-il trop de normes on a une
tendance naturel à surtransposer les
normes qui viennent de l'Europe il y a
aussi une difficulté d'avoir un discours
en France et un autre comportement à
Bruxelles ça on l' bien observé
j'indique d'ailleurs que la question
était très pertinente de madame la
sénatrice Christina Pluchet mercredi aux
question d'actualité au gouvernement qui
a posé cette problématique de
comportements différents selon qu'on est
en métropole ou selon qu'on est à
Bruxelles donc souent le PACT vert à
Brell le Mercosur c'est un sujet par
exemple c'est un sujet donc on comprend
bien que d'autres que certains
agriculteurs ou cultivateurs ou autres
qui travaillent dans le domaine
alimentaire ont besoin de
l'international donc tout ça c'est de
retrouver une stratégie de fond qui
permette à chacun de pouvoir s'en sortir
et notamment aux exploitants qui
manifestent aujourd'hui de pouvoir vivre
de travail alors la question de
l'environnement puisque la question est
posée bien sûr qu'il faut respecter
l'environnement mais aucun agriculteur
n'est pas n'est hostile à cela la
question c'est dans quelles conditions
avec quels moyens et qu'est-ce qu'on lui
donne pour permettre de le respect de
cet environnement donc n'pposons pas
tout le monde Je par mais mais prenons
compte des situations et définition
d'une stratégie souveraine et ben merci
François Noël buffet d'avoir été
l'invité de Parlement Hebdo merci à vous
et merci à tous d'avoir su suivi cette
émission et on vous retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour suivre les temps forts de
l'aualité au
[Musique]
Parlement